but it is 1 month without a drop of
alcohol you're making me cry again you
are a completely different functioning person
and I am so proud of you jacn this is [Music]
huge super quick here folks I really want to talk
about my sponsor today homog glob so I'm a super
organized person but I'm a very messy person
and this is quite the Dilemma for me because
I cannot feel organized when things are messy so
I really appreciate the value of having someone
with actual cleaning skills who like sees a
pile and puts it away to come and lend some
much needed support So homog glow is a five-star
cleaning service with super affordable prices way
cheaper than most services that I've paid for
in the past and definitely worth it to save my
marriage and my ability to get work done but the
way it works is you go to home hom Glow's website
to choose the day and time that you're looking
for and the duration of your cleaning and you'll
be able to see all the available cleaners along
with their background checks photos and reviews
so if you have someone that you've worked with
before you can rebook that same person and you
can schedule it for that week or like a month
from now if you want to rebook your cleanings
on a regular basis you can also sign up for their
forever clean membership which saves you $30 an
hour on future cleanings or unlimited cleanings
for $19 an hour hour all of which are backed by
their happiness guarantee and the cleaners are
really super incentivized to do a good job because
100% of the cleaning fees and tips go directly to
them I don't know about you but I just feel like
I can work so much more efficiently and calmly
when I'm not living in chaos this service is only
available in the United States but if you need a
little occasional support for your mental health
or to take a huge domestic Duty off of your plate
head to homog glow.com slabby or scan the QR code
to get your first 3 hours of cleaning for only
$19 hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
Kitchen today we'll be catching up with our girl
jacn on her journey and talking more broadly about
what happens to your body and weight when you stop
drinking this comes at a time in the year when
traditionally there is a lot of excessive drinking
when binge drinking basically becomes part of the
culture and it's borderline acceptable to get
blackout drunk at the company party L it her
head it's happening it is also a time when stress
depression and anxiety related to finances family
and past trauma can result in people turning to
alcohol to cope it can be a really hard season for
a lot of folks with histories of misuse of alcohol
or who want to explore reducing their regular use
but if you are Sober Sober curious or just looking
to cut back I do recommend watching Jacqueline's
video in its entirety I'm just going to give
you the CO's notes of where she's at up until
I went through a traumatic incident I partied I
drink alcohol socially I was just drinking like
everybody else right when I launched my lipsticks
that was the worst time of my entire life and
during that time I turned to alcohol I started
drinking alcohol in a very normal way again right
so I thought like my relationship with alcohol is
good again because this is the way everybody drank
I was no longer using it to run but I lost like
10 to 12 lbs and it was hard work like it was not
easy cuz again I was still drinking was I drinking
you know heavily no I was still consuming alcohol
so when I went to New York for my birthday I was
drinking sangrias and I was drinking margaritas
and I was just drinking whatever I got home
it weighed myself and I was like oh my God I
hadn't weighed myself in several weeks so in that
time frame I had gained 12 lbs and I was like I'm
sorry we did not just gain back everything that
we lost and that was my moment wow that is a very
powerful story and I bet at telling that a lot
of folks can identify with even if they don't
identify as having a problem with alcohol we all
have have a moment where we realize that something
in our life is no longer serving us whether it's a
disordered eating pattern an addiction a person a
job a place Etc no one else can get you to that
point you really have to reach that moment on
your own but after that moment Jaclyn dumped out
a bottle of Cheetos and vowed to stop drinking and
at the time of posting she has been 90 days sober
that is amazing so let's hear about the benefits
jacine experienced thus far so when I stopped
drinking I did not do it for for any physical
effects I did it 100% for my mental health and I
just wanted to feel good that's all I cared about
I'm really happy that that was the mindset that
I had because I didn't see any physical changes
for a little bit I started all new habits okay
I started taking walks I started eating so much
sugar and now the alcohol is far and long gone
out of my system I love sugar I did change my
diet as well I changed my workout routine as well
and now I I've lost 23 lbs ah it's crazy you guys
it's crazy I was working my titties off it's still
sugar even if you're just drinking clear alcohol
with club soda because now the weight literally
falls off of me now hear me out I did not lose
any weight not even a pound for the first two
weeks something happened between like the one
month Mark and the 3month mark where I lost like
close to 20 lbs in 2 months I am so sharp every
single person in my life is like what the I have
so so much damn energy I don't require as much
sleep I have lost 4 in on my waist my rosacea is
gone my average heart rate has gone down by 15
beats per minute my blood work is crazy my doctor
was like this looks like a different person first
of all I am so proud of Jacqueline like this is
what the journey should be about if you recall
Jaclyn spent months I don't know maybe years on a
weight loss journey and even though I was rooting
for her to meet her goals as a dietitian I had a
lot of reservations about her approach basically
with each episodes we would see jacine pull the
rins super super hard and then have a weekend
out where she would say it I'm going to live my
best life where she would drink and eat and be
married rinse and repeat and not only is this
over restrict binge repeat cycle a very common
Pitfall for people who are trying to lose weight
but the alcohol piece was probably also playing
a significant role in The Struggle but the fact
that she went into this journey of giving giv up
alcohol not for the promise of finally losing
weight or you know reducing the puffiness in
her face or any other physical feature but
for the mental health benefits which clearly
have been huge is so important for maintaining
motivation because like she said she didn't see
any weight loss for a few weeks and she could
have easily said like oh my God I'm not going
out I'm miserable I can't have fun with my friends
and I have nothing to show for it but she stayed
the course and I'm so glad she did because yeah
those first few weeks of abstinence are probably
going to be really really tough what jacine has
shared here is super Brave and it really opens
up opportunities for more discussions like this
one and since I'm not a substance use counselor
or a psychologist I'm a dietician I wanted to talk
broadly about what happens to your body when you
stop drinking so weeks one and two are rough
so this is the clinical detox period and when
the withdrawal effects like insomnia anxiety
depression ability night sweats Etc are most
prominent after 2 weeks your liver is likely near
or fully recovered basically every time you use
alcohol some of your liver cells die and while we
are able to develop new cells prolonged misuse of
alcohol can reduce its ability to regenerate so
one of the major risks of alcohol used disorder
is curosis of the liver where you get a buildup
of fats in the liver But after those 2 weeks of
abstinence you'll likely physically see signs
of liver recovery like clear whiter eyes and
greater energy like Jaclyn later described now
after 2 weeks this is generally where we see the
most physical and mental health benefits you'll be
sleeping better you may see improvements in your
skin better digestion and a lot more this is also
when you'll likely see a dramatic reduction in any
kind of puffiness or bloating as you stop holding
on to excess fluid especially in the face and it's
also when you may start to lose weight which lines
up very nicely with Jaclyn's time line and her
description of the weight loss kind of suddenly
melting off most research suggest that lower
moderate drinking is not associated with weight
gain but excess alcohol intake is so I want to
talk about the reasons why alcohol makes it a lot
harder to lose weight and why for a lot of folks
quitting can often be the spark that ignites the
weight loss fire so why do you lose weight when
you stop drinking reason number one you consume
fewer calories this is the most obvious reason
but if you're in the habit of having having let's
say 1 to two drinks on a week night and 2 to three
on a weekend and I'm being conservative even
if you're choosing perfectly clean drinks like
Jaclyn suggested that she would you are racking
up an extra th000 to 3,000 calories per week just
from the alcohol alone and this does not include
any mixes or syrups or any late night restaurant
or bar foods that you may feel more inclined
to consume when your inhibitions are down so
of course when you remove the calories from
alcohol you are naturally creating a calorie
deficit even if you don't change a single thing
about the food so that is Captain Obvious reason
number one reason number two you can burn fat not
just booze so when you consume alcohol your liver
preferentially burns the alcohol which means that
calories from everything else that you eat get
stored as fat particularly around the midsection
so this is where the pet name bear belly comes
from and it's actually this intraabdominal fat
that is the most metabolically dangerous for your
health one study found that men who drank more
than three drinks per week were 80% more likely
to have belly fat than those who drank less which
goes to show that even what might be considered
like social drinking quantities can increase
the risk and make it harder to lose that fat
and speaking of body composition reason number
three is that you can finally gain or maintain
muscle mass when you quit no one ever built
muscle in the bar and so even if you are working
out frequent excessive alcohol consumption can
negatively impact muscle growth basically alcohol
appears to interfere with signaling Pathways that
tell the body to build and retain muscle it can
also affect the hypothalamic pituitary gonadal
system which lowers our testosterone levels and
while most research in this area have been done on
men it's important to note that women also need a
certain level of testosterone to build muscle
you'll also just likely have more energy for
exercise if you're not bogged down by hangovers
and fatigue reason number four you'll have fewer
food cravings so we went into detail on how
cortisol affects our body weight in my video
right here but alcohol is a stressor on the body
so it increases our cortisol levels beyond what
is normal which plays a role in that belly fat
piece or that beer belly piece but it can also
increase our cravings for higher calorie foods
interestingly and I'm not Jaclyn's dietician so
I don't have a daytoday play byplay here but it
sounded like she replaced her use of alcohol with
sugar as a temporary dopamine hit to help pull her
out of some of those depressive episodes in those
early weeks of the detox and then later on as she
got past that hump she was naturally just wanting
to make choices that felt good to her body and
again this totally makes sense as the withdrawal
symptoms subsided and our hormones regulated post
detox reason number five you'll sleep better I
know we often talk about passing out after having
a few drinks and while alcohol may seem like a
sleep aid because it's a depressant it actually
interferes with quality sleep overc consumption
of alcohol is associated with significant sleep
disturbance lower slow wave sleep and more rapid
eye movement sleep than normal the result is
that you are chronically fatigued and poor
sleep is consistently associated with increased
hunger hormones food cravings and cortisol levels
all of which can increase the risk of weight game
there are obviously many other reasons why overc
consumption of alcohol can impact your weight
but the question question remains do you have
to completely abstain to see the benefits do you
need to quit cold turkey to lose weight well for
some folks yeah it might be All or Nothing not
because of the risk of weight gain but because
even one drink can trigger overuse some people
are also just more sensitive to the effects
than others but generally speaking the research
suggests that light to moderate alcohol intake is
not associated with weight or fat gain so how
much is too much again highly individualized
but I'm currently of the thought that less is
more here in Canada we actually just updated
our low-risk alcohol drinking guidelines from 10
drinks per week for women and 15 for men to just
two drinks per week that is a huge huge leap but
these guidelines have taken into consideration the
risks of cancer heart disease stroke and bodily
harm to yourself and others via drinking and
driving or fighting or other illegal activity and
honestly this is kind of what I suggest sticking
to as well at two drinks per week you are very
highly unlikely to experience any of the weight
gain risk factors that we just talked about
nor any of the more important negative mental
and physical health outcomes so if you're sober
or sober curious or just looking to cut back on
alcohol as we head into drink and culture Prime
Time with the holidays here are some my top tips
number one learn to say no you don't have to
say yes to every single event invite that you
receive so set a weekly cap on going out before
the invitations start rolling in and then send a
thank you card with your regrets when you've
met your Mac number two set a time limit for
your event attendance arrive at parties early on
before everyone else has had too much to drink
and commit to heading home early to maintain
your Healthy nighttime routine number three
offer or bring non-alcoholic options a festive
mocktail cider or hot cocoa gives you something
to look forward to Beyond just Seltzer and it's
something that everyone else can enjoy I've also
learned from my pregnancy days that it is best
to have something in your hands at all times so
that hosts or servers aren't constantly asking
you what you want to drink number four start
some non-drinking traditions if you're hosting or
organizing a holiday event make some socializing
suggestions that don't revolve around booze so
like having a holiday movie night or ice skating
or Holiday Light tours or night skiing are all
super fun ways to socialize without alcohol and
finally practice polite decline llies whether you
are completely abstaining or trying to limit your
consumption practice the polite response when your
friends or family start to pressure you to drink
it could be like I'm good with this or I'm pacing
myself or I'm driving tonight or I'm cutting back
all these are really quick responses that really
shouldn't need any more details so there's lots of
reasons to cut back on alcohol consumption weight
loss is really just one of many and arguably is
one of the least important perks in the context
of overall health and jacine is a really inspiring
example of this she went into her sober Journey
not looking to lose weight but ironically it made
something she had previously been working her
off for just happened the unexpected but much
desired side effect of really changing her whole
life for the better so please whether you're a
Jaclyn fan or not leave her some love here I
really hope she sees this because I am rooting
for her 100% And I am so glad that she had the
courage to share her journey with the rest of us
and on that note that's all that I have for
you guys I hope you have a safe and healthy
holiday season if you are someone you know is
struggling with alcohol use disorder I'm going
to leave a link below to some resources to help
and I will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music] bye